for much of the day the marine on guard
outside the west wing signaled the
president was inside
a president considering his options late
in delivering his decisions
when he appeared an hour after expected
the objective was unity among western
nations clarity and tranche one of an
unprecedented package of sanctions
we're implementing full blocking
sanctions
on two large russian financial
institutions
veb
and their military bank we're
implementing comprehensive sanctions on
russian sovereign debt
that means we've cut off russia's
government
from western financing it can no longer
raise money from the west and cannot
trade in its new debt on our markets or
european markets either but also from
the american president a simple question
one posed carefully intentionally to
nudge consciences globally to pit right
against wrong
who in the lord's name does putin think
gives him the right to declare
new so-called countries
on territory that belong to his
neighbors
this is a flagrant violation of
international law and demands a firm
response from the international
community
this was not the full list of
unprecedented sanctions that president
putin has been threatened with so many
times but nor was it designed to be the
invasion wasn't full scale and the
sanctions are incremental the deterrence
is gone if they're all imposed now the
problem is that that strategy may not be
working it's plainly clear that so far
president putin is not deterred
at the state department america's top
diplomat hosted the ukrainian foreign
minister
good afternoon but beyond the messages
of support and solidarity what are the
diplomatic options to prevent bloodshed
in ukraine now
the united states and i personally
remain committed to diplomacy if russia
is prepared to take demonstrable steps
to provide the international community
with any degree of confidence that it's
serious about de-escalating and finding
a diplomatic solution
we will proceed in coordination with
allies and partners based on russia's
actions
and the facts on the ground
but we will not allow russia to claim
the pretense of diplomacy
at the same time it accelerates its
march down the path of conflict and war
inside this administration a lingering
question is now more urgent than ever is
president putin rational is he driven by
strategy or recklessness the answer
worryingly they don't know mark stone
sky news in washington